[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
March 27th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
it was one of the most expensive things
you'll purchase in your life but what if
after you've selected a house and
started the paperwork process you
realize there's a chance you might not
be able to hold up your end of the deal
Wall Street Journal personal finance
reporter Veronica dagger wrote about
contingency Clauses often written into
home buying contracts Veronica thanks
for being with us thanks for having me
Jr so Veronica who tends to most often
write these contingency Clauses into
home buying contracts well they are
common with both sellers and buyers
because they can protect both sides of
the the equation there these days the
buyers are writing them in more but also
some people who are in the tech field
interestingly enough are writing these
contingencies in to Clauses both buyers
and sellers who work in tech for example
I spoke to a seller who worked in the
technology area he lost his job he was
on a special type of Visa which allows
him to stay in the country long story
short he didn't have a job job and he
wanted to sell his house but if he was
going to be able to get a new job he
didn't want to sell his house so he had
a contingency that said look if I get
another job within 30 days the sale of
my house is off but if I can't find
another job in 30 days I'll still go
ahead and sell my house to you
interestingly enough I'm seeing buyers
ask for this too people in Tech and
people in banking because we've seen so
much uncertainty in banking these days
people who work in those Industries are
saying look if I lose my job before this
contract closes I will be able to get my
deposit money back on the house I'm not
going to lose that deposit money which
in some cases could be up to six figures
so depending on how expensive the house
is and so it's an important Hedge for
people to be able to back out of a
contract get that deposit money back and
minimize hard feelings that might happen
between a buyer and seller if things go
south what usually goes into these
Clauses what do they aim to do well
basically they give buyers and sellers
one or both of the parties a way to back
out a real estate contract if certain
conditions aren't met and basically the
sale of the home is contingent on one of
these conditions some of these
conditions could be an appraisal or they
could be a home inspection or they could
be a funding contingency and can talk a
little bit about those but there's
various contingencies you can add into a
contract depending on what you're
looking to hedge against what risk
you're looking to hedge against now the
home buying process often involves the
contract level the closing level where
in the home buying process do these
contingency Clauses typically come into
play you want to get that contingency
clause in any preliminary contract
before any money changes hands so before
you give over your deposit money to that
seller for that house usually it's held
in escrow it should be held in escrow by
the attorneys before you hand over any
money make sure you have in writing that
this deal could be called off if X and Y
don't happen it's really important
before any money changes hands you know
if you're still in the house shopping
stage no need to be talking about
contingencies to potential sellers you
may be buying from you don't want to
push yourself out of the process because
I think it is important to say if you're
a buyer and you add a contingency into a
contract or say you're looking for some
sort of contingency outright you're
generally less competitive as a buyer
there's still people out there these
cash buyers who will buy a house with no
mortgage no contingency sometimes even
sight unseen those people are very very
competitive buyers and so if you're in
one of those markets that still exists
out there just be wary that adding in a
contingency into your offer is going to
make you look weaker now what effect has
the housing market had on this trend of
writing and contingency Clauses well
it's interesting because during the
height of the pandemic fueled housing
frenzy no contingencies on behalf of
buyers were being asked for if you asked
for a contingency it was like see you
later and you're not going to win this
bid on this house there's too much
competition now though it's a much
different scenario mortgage rates have
almost doubled or more than doubled from
where they were during the height of the
frenzy we were at seven percent interest
rates on average for 30-year fixed
mortgages just the other week and so
because of the high interest rates on
mortgages there is less competition for
houses right now and when there's less
competition less buyers out there buyers
have more leverage in addition there's a
bit more inventory there's a a bit more
homes for sale this year than there were
last year and because there's more
choice not a ton more choice but there's
more choice that gives buyers more
leverage because sellers in many cases
aren't going to get those five offers
that they might might have gotten a year
ago maybe they're only getting one good
offer and if they have that one good
offer at that price that they're looking
for they may be willing to work with you
and agree to the contingency that you're
looking for now what other kinds of
contingency Clauses are written into
home buying contracts that might not
deal with potential job loss or
something that might create you know
some sort of a financial shortfall well
one thing that we're seeing coming back
which is a nice thing for buyers is that
it's okay to ask for a home inspection
contingency again back in the day I'm
meeting the height of the pandemic when
the housing market was moving so quickly
many buyers were having to waive
inspections and take that house as is
and as we know there's people who have
regrets because they realize there are
some major repairs or major leaks that
are occurring or cracks in the
foundation so you don't have to forego
that Home Inspection anymore to get the
house you can say this offers contingent
on passing the home inspection based on
this criteria and then we'll move ahead
with the deal so that's one thing that
we're seeing again which is really good
news for buyers all right that's Wall
Street Journal personal finance reporter
Veronica dagger Veronica thanks so much
for being with us thanks for having me
Jr and that's your money briefing I'm
J.R Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
foreign
[Music]